hello everyone this game comes as a
suggestion from a subscriber and it
comes from a very strong tournament it
was the candidates was played in 1959
determent was played in bled Belgrade
and Zagreb and it featured eight players
six players who called qualified from
the Interzone all tournament in Porto
Roche in 1950 1958 and two players who
achieved first new places in the
previous candidate series that's vastly
smyslov and Paul Karras and this is one
of the games from the tournament we have
Michael towel here and vasily smyslov so
future world champion versus former
world champion very exciting match and I
will tell you something about who also
participated in this tournament I
already did a couple of games from this
tournament but I hope at one point to
cover all the games from this tournament
as they are all quite amazing and I will
tell you about the results of the
tournament after the game so it all had
the white pieces and he played efore his
opponent vasily smyslov plays c6 and
Bobby Fischer also played in this
tournament and he said that the Russians
were cowards as all of them were playing
the CARICOM defense he said that they
they are not real men as they will not
play the sicilian against Bobby Fischer
so sisters by Smith look we have b3 b5
this is the Braer variation Knight to d2
now II five and here 90 G to f3 Knight
to d7 and here tau pushes v4 allowing
some exchanges in the center but in the
end it will somewhat favor white D
captures on e4 Knight captures he
capture some d4 and Queen captures
Knight G to f6 and here
Bishop to g5 pinning the Knight Bishop
to e7 and here talc castles Queen side
and off all the lines the Talcott play
with white I think this could be
actually one of his favourite as this is
only move 9 and already all of his
pieces are ideally placed that the
bishop is coming to c4 or d3 depending
on what black plays so he doesn't really
have to even try to develop the way he
would like to develop here we have
castles and here tall could play a lot
of things for example he could go for a
series of exchanges let's say knife
captures on f6 Bishop
Bishop Tadros Queen captures and let's
say Bishop to d3
Queen characters Knight captures and
after Knight to c5 it's a pretty cool
position probably if tall wanted he
could go for this but doing this with
the white pieces as thought himself says
it would be a crime against its chess
even though this is not the exchange
variation of the French but still so
after its missile castled here typed all
played Knight to d6
so if sniffle wants to exchange
something he can't I mean he can but he
would have to give up a bishop for a
night here and that would be that would
be quite deadly
so it's missile goes Queen to a5
attacking the a to pawn and here tau
plays Bishop to c4 defending the a to
pawn we have b5 now and this is move 12
so b5 was move 11 and here we have
Bishop to d2 Bishop to d2 is is a
complicated move which is normal because
style plays it but that could also go
for something like Bishop captures on f7
here and after rook captures Knight
captures and after King captures came to
be one defending the a to pawn and the
White has compensation here I'm what is
even better here
rook th rook is coming t1 there are
gonna be some problems and the e-file
here
so tau could have gone for this but he
had something else in mind
after b5 he played Bishop to b2 now
attacking the Queen we have Queen 286
and now comes Knight to f5 so what do
you do here if you capture the bishop on
c4 of course Knight captures Bishop on
e7 so smithville first plays Bishop to
d8 getting the knight the bishop out of
the way and this is the strongest move
and here this is move 14 tower plays
Queen to h4 and this is I mean this is a
beautiful position as tall has already
created madness on the board the real
question is can smith self capture the
bishop because tall of course is
planning Queen to g5 going for the g7
pawn let's say let's say you don't how
can you how can you improve on your
defense here if you play something like
h6 simply trying to stop the Queen from
coming to g5
then your whole defenses get shattered
after night captures on h6g captures now
Bishop captures attacking the rook on f8
also Queen to g5 check is still a threat
followed by Queen to g7 checkmate
so after 928 defending the g7 square
Queen to g3 check simply winning King
has to move now Bishop captures Knight
captures and the rout capture 78 both of
the ninth night Knights are in line of
the rook this is just terrible for white
for black this is a completely winning
for Tao
so after this Queen to h4 move
Smithville's played B captures on c4 and
this is in fact the strongest move and
here topless of course Queen to g5
moving for the g7 pawn and Smith's love
plays Knight to h5 he offers a piece
back now what's the idea well he's
offering a piece back because he just
captured one piece on c4 so he doesn't
want to be up too much material against
all and the other reason is that this is
the only defense
so if Powell would were to capture this
night for example Queen captures then
comes Knight to f6 attacking the Queen
Queen to g5 again threatening checkmate
on g7 but now Bishop captures Queen
captures and after g6 kicking away the
Queen let's say Queen to c5
now either comes the immediate Queen
captures on a2 with a better position
for black or even even stronger Knight
to e4 and it's actually Todd that's
losing this game after Queen moves
protecting the a to pawn Queen captures
pawn captures and now Knight captures an
f2 simply winning the exchange so after
this night to h5 move by Smith's love at
a plate the only move that allows him to
continue his attack he played night to
h6 check King to h8 this is the only
move as the pawn is pinned and here
Queen captures on h5 and in this
position
Smith Slav captured on a - the problem
with capturing the knight here for
example if you play G captures and h6
you get Bishop the c3 check and after
blocking with f6 now comes Queen
captures on h6 threatening to capture
the rook the the threat is rook captures
night and the seven and then Queen
captures rook on f8 this will be
checkmate so after roof - G
now would come Knight to g5 again
threatening checkmate on h7 so you'd
have to you'd have to give up the
exchange here rook captures Queen
captures and now it seems like Smith's
level would have a pretty clever defense
with Queen to a5 defending the best dead
bishop on b8 also offering to exchange
Queens and g5 as now the Queen's are
eyeing each other and if they'll capture
screen with the bishop then the f6 pawn
is no longer pin pin then Smith's love
can capture tiles Queen and g5 but here
Queen to h6 again with the same threat
rook captures night and Queen to f8
checkmate and after Queen to c5
defending the d f8 square now comes Luke
H 2 e 1 and there are no good moves here
for black this is completely winning for
white for example Bishop to e7
now comes rock to e3 and this rock is
either coming to g3 with someone stopped
about threats or if we play something
like Knight to e5 now comes a beautiful
series of moves rook captures on e5 pawn
captures and in five and now there is a
forced checkmate in three moves it's a
pretty pretty good position for you to
pause the video and try to find what at
all would have have in this position if
it's miss Lord decided to capture the
night and h6 so I do hope you were able
to solve it if any of you have paused
the video for those of you who found it
you're an excellent player and also if
you just want to enjoy the show
here White has better captures on e5
first you remove the Queen Queen
captures an e5 and now comes rope to d8
check as you had to remove the Queen
from c5 because now when the bishop
captures rook the Queen from c5 will no
longer be protecting the f8 square so
first rook to the 8th check Bishop
captures and now the queen is free to
deliver checkmate
Queen to f8 and this is checkmate so
after this Queen captures on h5 it would
it wouldn't be that great force myself
to capture the night here so he played
the Queen captures an a2 we have Bishop
the c3 now pinning the g7 pawn and also
making an escape route for the coup for
King as Smith was threatening Queen 2
1 checkmate and here this is the last
opportunities missile had to defend
properly here a move that would keeps
miss love in the game is Bishop to f6
but instead of Bishop to f6 missiles
played at Knight to f6 and here it is
all over I would ask you to pause the
video and find the move again but if I
ask you to find a move now you all know
what tiles going to play here top plate
Queen captures on f7 and now of course
miss love is not going to fall for row
captures Queen rook to captures and the
eighth with checkmate whatever black
plays Knight the g8 rookie at present g8
but he has to play Queen to a1 check
King comes to d2 and now as Palace
threatening to capture the rope with
checkmate he played rook captures on f7
now tile captured Smith lost Queen rook
capture sorry first night to f7 would
check King moves and now rook captures
on a one and here's missile has to
capture the night on f7 or else he will
be down a piece so King captures and
this is moved 22 Smith's log is done the
exchange and he can freely resign this
game as there is no way he's going to
win this being down the exchange against
all but he tried he tried a couple of
more moves
we have knife to e5 check by towel King
to e6 now Knight captures on c6 grabbing
another pawn Knight to e4 check King tv3
and Bishop to b6 with check table blocks
with Bishop to d4 and it was in this
position that tile resigned the game so
this is move 26 I'm sure Smith didn't
want to resign and move 22 because I
think it has to be below 25 moves for it
to be considered a miniature and he
didn't want his game against tal to be
considered as a miniature in history
books but to his unfortune this game won
the brilliant surprise had the 1959
candidates tournament and of course
everyone in the world saw this game and
everyone in the world who will ever play
chess will see this game so doesn't
matter that's missile played a couple of
more moves you know
everyone saw the game and you know he
should have resigned and moved 22 this
really made no sense but yeah I do hope
you enjoyed this like I said it was a it
was a pretty wild tournament of course
you all know Michael tal wanted he
wanted one and a half points
I had a Paul Karras and yeah it was it
was quite the tournament I don't think I
don't think I have the exact standings
for this tournament but you know I'll
crush the field definitely and as you
all know next year he will face Mikhail
Botvinnik and win the World Chess
Championship title so that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it as usual you can
check to my previous videos here I would
like to thank quality refurbished
computers for contribution to my channel
thanks a lot - really appreciate it and
don't spend the entire evening you know
watching YouTube and chess videos as it
is Valentine's so if you have a
girlfriend or a wife you know take her
somewhere spend some time with her and
if you don't you know you should go get
one so thank you all and I will see you
soon